what'd you think of Avatar too
I watched it in 3D I saw in 3D
unpopular opinion I liked it
why is that unpopular I think most
people like I think I mean if you're
going critically I can see I have issues
with it too but just enjoying the movie
experience I loved it I haven't seen it
and I love that Kate Winslet played a
Native American oh really that was her
that was her she's great as a native
yeah the voice the voice was very good
wild yeah native voice
um here's my consensus if you want to
hear it
I didn't want to see it
um I did everything I could not to see
it
but I people would tell me like it's
great a gene I think Gene Hong was like
it's pretty good right so I bought the
glasses I was by myself I was at the
universal over there by myself right no
I was in the middle and I just remember
like there was two fat guys I said I was
to find but two fact I sat next I was
like squished in you know what I mean
and I was by myself and I had the
glasses on I was like oh my God I should
just shoot myself in the face this is
[ __ ] such a [ __ ] loser
and I would say that you know I mean
with and squish and the movie started
and I was just really
captivated by the whole thing number one
visually so good it's just it's you know
it's like
um you know if you watch
any Scorsese movie or any movie like of
course he's as a genius but you know you
can kind of go
you know what I can set up that camera
angle
like I understand where the camera is I
understand how it's kind of made you
know I mean you do a wide shot close-up
you know this and that right
with this movie it's like if somebody if
James Cameron came up to me and goes hey
dude
um you're gonna do Avatar three direct
it
I just I would look at him and go I I I
I I I I wouldn't even know where I
wouldn't even know where to begin I like
that's how yeah just the idea the
daunting task you know I mean it's just
you don't know how anything's made right
it's like especially the Watershed The
Watershed and just the Angles and just
the seamless integration between CGI and
human and then the the
um you really felt the nature of this
one
you know I mean you you really got
invested like oh oh my god I think I'm a
uh you know oh what do you call it
people are really into the oceans it's
kalila yeah I'm kalila no like what
conservationist or whatever is that this
word people like the ocean no but people
that are really into nature and all that
stuff that are like Pro nature hippies
what do you call them
and anyway
I was like oh I want to save Dolphins
that's particularly the feeling oh
whales whales wait the whale stuff no I
have my argument against the world it's
a spoiler alert but bro let's argue
about that we did motion capture whales
I know it's legit can I just say a
spoiler thing it's been out for a while
right yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna say what my little
thing was right what's your gripe here's
my gripe with the movie this is pokey
for sure poke poke gym I'm gonna poke um
James Cameron I have my arguments number
one that that kid that played Spider
oh I kid yeah yeah he I I don't know
about that character
he was a device for you know yeah but
yeah I don't know where he I don't like
it when there's a character where it's
like I don't know where you stand bud
I know who you said you're on I don't
know what the [ __ ] going on I like you
I don't like you you know there's like a
lot of like maybe that's maybe that's
what a good character is but here's my
thing so in the movie they're
slaughtering whales humans are in
Pandora right but the difference between
these whales and our whales is the what
they communicate they straight up talk
they don't talk but but they they can
they you know like what do you call the
blue things
Navi the navi right have relationships
with these whales like how are your kids
oh you take dancing classes yeah they're
having like fun yeah how's dancing
classes you know I mean the whales like
they're pretty good they communicate Not
Just Between the whales with the navi oh
yeah yeah they're like ethically yeah
they're like telepathically connected
you know because they their tails and
their [ __ ] you know I mean strings I
don't know how that works what's the
connection yeah but you know how they
connect to the leaves and stuff like
that right so um and so they're like
they know each other their family right
and then these humans come with their
[ __ ] I mean and they kill them like
they killed a mother whale that the navi
love that they've had hundreds of years
relationships relationship with in front
of their kid the whale baby slaughtered
it right and you're like infuriated
you're I'm in there with my glasses
going what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] you hear me
do something right right until I realize
why they're doing it and I'm like ah
that was your point I mean how do you
feel about Rhino I'll tell you what it
was okay
they're killing these magical whales
right
and then you don't know why you're like
what are you gonna sell the meat right
they go